India is a country of
languages cultures religions customs and
so on and as a result the
divisive nasaan many social issues but
your films have created a truly devoted
and United fan base that's united in
their love of you Shahrukh Khan and
they're they're uniting across ethnic
and national boundaries even outside of
India yet at the same time some of your
films do deal with social issues so my
name is Khan it confronted racial
profiling after 9/11 and chuck de Indias
discussed bigotry and sexism those are
the stories that I write but at the same
time we also do have films that are
sheer entertainment so what is it about
your work that appeals to and unites
audiences that are normally at odds with
each other and also do you feel that
films have or maybe they already have a
role in discussing or examining social
issues I think they have but if they
make it their prime concern then they
don't remain so they're gonna remain
entertainment I say this to everyone
it's a little saying that you know
messages are for the post box post
offices they're not for entertainment
you don't give messages through
entertainment I'm a big believer of that
you need to entertain people you know
two and a half hours in a dark room come
back have fun and enjoy yourselves and
entertainment can be sad it can be more
but it can be bright it can be colorful
it can be as silly as some of the films
that I do but I I truly believe that the
reason I think I was analyzing it I keep
analyzing it because everyone keeps
asking me how did this happen that
people everywhere like you and I
I cannot go beyond the answer that has
to do with my dimples
is the most intellectual answer I've
been able to give myself yeah and you
see how far you go with this but but I
think the reason that my cinema or the
kind of films like I think I got a
little fortunate that in the 90s when I
started working there was a time when
eighties was the time of you know a lot
of aggressive films and ugly
bell-bottoms and good collars and
strange hairstyles in Indian cinema and
somehow the younger generation which was
kind of me also that time was 24 23 they
all wanted to have a little more love
amidst them you know not
anti-establishment work not anti-social
world they just wanted to have feeling
of love and I think I did a lot of films
like that
so whether it was Dilwale Dulhaniya Le
Jayenge Kuch Kuch Hota Hai and I think I
think as cliched as it may sound but it
makes me believe that love really is the
universal language you know so you can
be in a country with hundred different
languages as you stayed and I come down
to Yale to America to London I go to
South America and people in Germany who
don't speak a language at all and and
you know they they all they all seem to
like that cinema I asked one lady a six
year old lady who actually took the
first Indian film to Germany she used to
work for a big television studio and I
asked her so I was sitting with her at
night and I said why do you want to do
anything why do you guys like in the
film you know I go and shoot in Germany
and there like hundreds of Germans who
loveth um yeah and they don't speak
Hindi at all which is October October
after no no and you know nothing they
make these guttural sounds but they
don't speak
and and you know they they look very
imposing because from the outside we all
have preset notions of each country and
country people from there and I asked
them I said why do you like Hindi films
why do you like this kind of cinema so
they told me that I have a button to
drive a car I put on a button of the car
starts I have a button to make coffee I
have a button to go up and down in
Germany we didn't have a button to cry
and you give us that button you're fools
give us that button and I think you know
and and and so I equate these two things
I think love as beautiful items as it is
also makes you cry and in a good way
sometimes in a bad way but I think the
the togetherness of this I think the
whole human community around the world
you will find two universal truths they
all love and they all cry